let me just give you an idea of how
devastating this explosion was we're in
the building that sky
uses as our office here at downtown
beirut
this must be about 600 meters away from
the bath perhaps a bit a bit longer
and you can see that everything has been
essentially destroyed
these big metal doors that you see are
reinforced
metal doors uh that are the entrance to
this
uh building and we're just gonna walk
out here you can see this has severely
destroyed
everything
these are residential blocks but as we
get to the end of this road
you can see that we essentially get to
the center of town a neighborhood called
downtown beirut
and all across here the facades of these
buildings
have been destroyed they've been serious
damage
all of the glass windows on this side of
the building
have been blown out if you look up here
you can see the impact of those blasts
that have totally dismantled those
shutters there
and destroyed some of the way the
windows and the doors
let's just go a bit further on here
so far the authorities here in lebanon
are saying that what caused this
explosion
uh was seemingly an industrial accident
a fireworks
uh depot or some sort of fireworks
factory near the port
of beirut or in the port of beirut had
some sort of explosion
and that's led to an almighty blast and
videos emerging on social media of just
how
severe that blast was but let's just
carry on looking down here you can see
glass
strewn across the floor all across the
floor here
and look at this building now this
building which has been
unused for several months now but let's
have a look here just have a look at how
destroyed the front of that building is
parts of the the door the walls
the glass facades totally blown out
and if we just walk out here into the
main street
this is what we call uh martyrs square
it is central beirut
it has been for the best part of the
year the epicenter of
protest taking place in the country but
today
it is a site of total damage and
devastation
if i show you here for example this
building just to give you an idea of how
damaged it is
how far this damage
has reached if you swing back around
what you're seeing straight down the
road
towards those lights at the end of the
road that is the port for harbour and
it's there
that this explosion is thought to have
taken place
if you look at the sirens the ambulances
police vehicles fire engines
hour and a half if not longer they have
been non-stop
the authorities are saying that there
could be many many injured i saw
across downtown many civilians are
covered in blood covered
in shards of glass clearly very
seriously injured and i'm sure
that the scene closer to the port just
about five or six hundred meters from
where we are
would be a scene of utter devastation as
ambulances as fire brigades as a
security forces try and make their way
there
to help those who may have been caught
up in this terrible explosion